good morning cake it's tuesday my book
the anthropocene reviewed comes out one
week from today i am a small boat and
these are big waves anyway it's question
tuesday the day that i answer real
questions from real nerdfighters let's
get right to it
out of 14 years of vlogbrothers in jokes
what's your favorite it's when hank left
an eye out of the word communication in
our 2007 intro and we had to think of a
reason so he said it was because there
is no i in brotherhood i still think
about that all the time
what is your opinion on frogs largely
positive what's the difference between
the physical book and the audiobook i
mean the main difference is that one is
primarily an eye experience and the
other is primarily an ear experience but
there are a few essays in the audiobook
that are not in the physical book and
there are things in the physical book
that are not in the audiobook
just because they're different ways of
telling stories and i wanted to reflect
that like in the physical book there's
this thing called a half title page and
i have very strong opinions about half
title pages so i wrote a review of half
title pages what's the strangest thing
someone has ever recognized you for
once i was in an airport store with my
best friend chris waters and after he
paid for his stuff i went up with my
magazine or whatever and the store clerk
was like listen this is a weird question
and i was like yeah i am john green and
the clerk was like no i already know
that what i'm wondering is how do you
know vince vaughn
so the strangest thing i've ever been
recognized for is being vince vaughn's
best friend
how do you manage to push through your
severe anxiety and function as a human
being well sometimes i don't function
very well but also i wouldn't say that i
push through it i would say that i try
to treat it and when necessary try to
accommodate it like i would any other
chronic health problem i know you have
an email for anthropocene reviewed
listeners to write in what's an email
that resonated with you
there are a lot but i feel like i can't
talk about them because they're too
personal people write into that email
address with such
raw emotion and i want to protect that
it actually reminds me of this moment
from my favorite movie harvey when the
main character talks about chatting with
strangers at a bar they tell me about
the big terrible things they've done and
the big wonderful things they'll do
their hopes and their regrets and their
loves and their hates
all very large because nobody ever
brings anything small
into a bar nobody ever brings anything
small into that email address either i
mean for writing to work
both reader and writer have to somehow
lay down their protective shields of
cynicism and commingle their
fear and yearning and hope and joy and
whatever else and i cannot tell you how
grateful i
am to the people who've done that with
the anthropocene reviewed like sometimes
when i'm reading i'll feel like the
author knows something about me that i
have never told
anyone and that will make me feel less
alone in those
amorphous depths of the self and that's
what i love most about
art and if the anthropocene reviewed can
be that for some people i feel
very very fortunate are there parts of
the book that wouldn't have worked on
the podcast
yeah most notably the picturey parts but
also like the wintry mix parts
did you include the word deadpan exactly
once in the anthropocene reviewed as you
have for every book you've written since
an abundance of catherine's
indeed i did that is another 14 year old
joke that i really enjoy
could you please pronounce some foreign
language titles of the book yes and with
great skill as per usual
in dutch it will be welcome on
anthropocene and in german it will be
vihat inhen das anthroposon bisher
gefalen i didn't know how to deal with
the question mark so i just sort of
raised my voice by the way i like the
german title so much i wrote the entire
concluding essay in the book about it
are the essays organized by date written
or alphabetical order and should i read
them in order like a novel or can i just
jump around
you can read it however you like i am
very over author's prescribing reading
experiences
the book belongs to you use it however
it can be useful but it's not organized
alphabetically or by date it's organized
by like a vague journey from childhood
to adulthood and then also a journey
from
hope to despair to hope wait what is
this book about exactly yeah i still
don't know i guess it's about awe
or connectedness or how weird it is that
temporary beings can conceive of
permanence and lastly what's on your
vision board this week
i really hope you like the anthropocene
reviewed book hank i'll see you on
friday
p.s i'm going on a virtual tour next
week for the anthem scene reviewed but
i'm also doing an event with the
wonderful dan howell about his book you
will get through this night more info
and tickets in the doobly-doo